I've never won any money in
in the leeches Tyler Arena so
maybe today will be the day but we'll
see
okay title Arena starting in a few
seconds
here we go
let me try and devote full Focus
playing Flawless fighter
layout should be okay
I'll play 95 this is
one of my go-to London lines
Queen C7 out of three and solid Theory
94 is common
H6 is common too
I think I studied Queen D3 here
threatening mates
but now what to do
thinking about take take G4 but
looks a little bit too risky
we've got some interesting structure
yeah E4 is a threat to play Queen D2
a little bit less space not the most
Pleasant
but trying to hold my grounds
down a lot of time so far
that's a good move
still trying to hold my ground
Rook D3
of Queen D7 rookie seven I think this is
okay
the E4 I have Queen D4 as well
so I want to provoke rookie seven
maybe not
so I want a pawn
yeah my Pawn probably overlooked this
move
but it's still not easy
yeah Queenie Sun's annoying
to play 91
those pawns kind of hanging
Rook D2 man
have this move
F5 is attached
what's up
I'm playing Knight G3 and go after E4
foreign
very tricky position
materials equal
oh no
it's still okay
turning this now
this is bad
some practical chances
foreign
yeah it's not working
[Music]
uh what to do got all played good game
though
got a little bit low on time there
okay got my heart rate pumping welcome
back Victor's neighbor
cannot be in do with that
yeah I cannot be in getting low on time
okay playing ehlers snow
it'll be a long tournament so gotta keep
composure
let's play some kind of English
playing a very simple like Italian setup
D6 castling
I'll bring the nail around
when I was younger I um
I had a book on the English opening by
karpov
and there are a lot of positions that
showed the setup for Black
looks pretty solid
play Rook I'll play Queen E7
maybe go for some night maneuver along
with F5
King hate is useful
yeah the bishop can exert some X-ray
vision
uh
uh play this first
take with Queen
or F5 should come with tempo
okay time management is much better this
game
C5 D5 Knight D6 Bishop E6
should probably include F6 at some point
wow
so the bishop will transfer to B8
take take
oh very tricky
if I took there's Bishop A3
so I'm holding off and taking the pawn
and the plan display not a five and
eventually capture the pawn
there is a weirdly similar theme in um a
game between Fabiano and alireza today
alireza had a pawn like very far
Advanced on D6
but it just survived there somehow
um I think here I can take and take
take immediately
it was Queen before I have Rook d8
oh there's Rook a seven
uh
that's not good
Queen A3
oh Queen A3 Knight C8 okay
Maybe by some miracle I'll hold on here
I am temporarily up upon but I'm under a
huge amount of pressure
why has a monster Bishop
so always keep in mind these ideas
so Queen A4
foreign
[Music]
so at least these things are defended
Queen G5 on tap
it's still up on time
some Sac opportunities
yeah that's a move Rook C8
[Music]
because Rook a and I take the bishop
hmm
okay
confusing position
night is going Hoppity Hoppity
oh no
okay
chess is a draw chess is a draw
I was up on time moves to that game and
then opponent played well a bishop Perry
became strong
you it's Potter and his girl pussed
happy 15.
all right
I do have the smart berserk extension so
I guess I'll follow it
I've got to win a game this tournament
at least I'm on the scoreboard
[Music]
I think Knight E3 here
um
Bishop E3 and Knight C4
it's already looking winning
like very winging
because a rook is stuck
and the Knight doesn't even get trapped
all right that was a cool opening trap
a full Rook
so now it's about time management
trying to ensure that
I don't get too long time
I F4
I'm trading a bit
E7 can sometimes be weak
in the half open file
[Music]
like Bishop moves I have Knight T2
hitting the rook and the pawn
okay Queen E3
got my Connect Four
connect three
yeah five is
a nice way to make progress
it still takes a little bit of work to
break through
want to play Knight G5
F6 and 96
there we go
getting closer
kudos to Black for resisting though
being lost for so many moves
okay
simplifying
plenty of time
uh
where's my mate
do it the old-fashioned way
okay
all right 170. the prediction is over
oh 92 let's go okay
LeapFrogs a lot of people with that one
got some berserking points
oh playing colicomsky
all right
commsky doesn't appear to be streaming
he could be but
um
who knows
so it's a king's Indian attack
yeah this is my go-to setup I delay C5
so I don't weaken D6
and the idea is to play this and this
sometimes A5 A4
uh let's play
Knight C6
kingside's a little bit loose
a visual H6 High division f8
um H4 is a good move
King h8 and H6 I guess
yeah komsky's probably pretty well
versed in these positions
it's already a big concession
oh no it's a good move
not losing though
at least immediately
trying to keep the time advantage
that's six
take
F6 doesn't work
hey Rook G8 that's such a sad move
the idea is to give a square for one of
the minor pieces
oh it doesn't ah it doesn't work
to take with Queen
oh that's not good
don't hurt me
don't like updated
yeah he played a good game I was like a
quintessential Kings Indian attack
got squeezed and then got turned into
juice
what to do
thank you streams on Twitch happy 22
months
all right so I've won one lost two
I'm not gonna berserk point is the Grand
Master
slightly low rated but uh
I'll show some respect
I think Knight A4 is acceptable
okay this is a slightly new territory
six will move
probably not
almost works though
playing Knight H3 first
foreign
do I want to trade Queens also probably
not
so H6 I can play this and then if we
trade I defend the pawn with a knight
C4 probably should come at some point
because vampasana take back with pawn
and
hopefully get in C4
also now F5 is attacked
which like I didn't even realize until
just then
can I go full Ham on the king side
Bishop d6's playable I think
so maybe bishop H for
G5 looks super risky
even though it would win a piece
okay the plan is to Triple up
attack the pin tonight
could play C3
some D4 prospects
I really want to take the bishop
so Bishop takes I take the Knight and
then take on D5
I will be down
oh no in that line I'm not Dom material
I'm down in exchange for a couple Pawns
okay now I have two minor pieces for The
Rook
also upon extra
interesting game
Rooks attacked 58 it's not played
if I could take the Rook
so it takes Ida D4
and now I'm happily up a piece
yeah the dust is settling
still kind of pinned
defend
the king is very safe
ooh
okay probably should not have a lot of
that
there there
just play this
perky three Queen D2 I still want to
play H3
Knight is too annoying here
oh it's also annoying there
I gotta move faster
oh man
okay I'm winning on time
God way too long time there
oh man
thank you m junior golf
or MJR golf
I appreciate the sub and the message
okay
staff again at a time double berserk
oh this is a fun one
this is a very fun one
and D4 doesn't really help
so queen of three out of 95 otherwise
yeah light's in trouble
that's a tricky move though
take
it should be fine
yeah this line could get messy
potentially
because Queen F3 is coming
foreign
I managed to say other piece but my
knight is a bit stuck
I'm losing the Knight
unless I have this move
I've spent a lot of time there
so rookie two Knight F1
maybe Rook F1
actually now that one looks better
yeah Knight is saved
now this is the beginning of the end for
white
or the end of the end
okay
that's nice
yeah the Stafford gamut line I mean it's
like crushing for black but it got a
little bit tricky there
so top 60.
nice to be on the streak
340 players here
playing vulva chess
I've definitely played the soccer games
will the chest before
yeah this is um like a bad version of
the scotch for white
but how do I punish it
a little bit greedy there
I did win a pawn
White's getting some compensation
Queen H4
threatening Bishop G4
also getting off the D file
okay I want to play 95.
I think I can take those
Rook takes I win The Rook Queen takes I
take and win a pawn
B6 Bishop B5
some Knight D4 move
Bishop B5 rookie six
foreign
it's hard to defend F3
because there is F4 Knight F3 King H1
play this so both pawns are hanging
take a rook before tick take
I think it's okay
I defend and win upon
so I'm up four pawns now
my knight is surviving
okay that was a pretty clean game
you just want a lot of Pawns
pretty early on too
uh I guess I'll berserk if it's telling
me it's a berserk
gotta follow it
try and ride the wave of momentum
it is nice when berserking like provokes
my opponent to preserve pack
so idea is Queen H3 and then gets some
attack
Queen is very nicely placed here
Jake with Pawn or Bishop
I'll take with Bishop
no more Knights on the board
um
soon to be no more Bishops on the board
F4
[Music]
queen size is pretty much locked down
want to play this
H5 G4
F6
[Music]
checkmates unexpected checkmates
sneaky Queen okay I'll take that
20 second place on the four game win
streak
yeah that was a hard-fought game
okay so a lot of chests to go
just past the half hour mark
oh playing Tamil Jerry we played OTB
in I think Abu Dhabi
I forget the game though
I remember like preparing against this
opponent
they're very strong bullet players so
berserking was maybe not the best
decision
that's a good move
actually I'm just in trouble here
and the the
I think I have to sack a pawn
episode 4 is coming
it's not pleasant
I think Knight C5
my hope is the light squares will treat
me well
Bishop B7 F3
try this first
Rook D1 and then Queen F3
threading this now and this
oh no my Bishop so I'm turning mace King
G1 I have other mates
how does white defend
Bishop E3 I take
rookie seven I take
somehow I think it's winning
okay I was very fortunate
got the berserking points there too
condensation worked out
14th Place
two berserk wins in a row
playing this person the cow dessert back
have a Dutch I'll play London
idea F6
or F3
like reverse Stonewall
I'm just trying to be solid
[Music]
um
I can win C6 and the wrestle pawns are
weak
B5 is attacked twice
foreign
attack twice
prevention work D2
[Music]
um
oh no
what I almost just happened there
I lost the Rook at some point but
I went on time
the final position is theoretically
drawn to black half mate though
oh black can't play King F2 it's almost
mating
um
but not quite
okay heart rate over 150.
I'm ahead of Rebecca Harris top 10.
oh man
that's nice that
um at least the last few opponents have
berserk back
it doesn't get easier
so C3 Sicilian yeah we played a lot
recently
and Bishop T3
we'll play Bishop B7
yeah
a common trap do I have F5 Rook C8
I have to go for it
I'm losing too much material though
I mean Bishop B7 is simple
I'll try and fight
Miracles are very possible to happen
as we saw in the previous game
Queen B6
between B6 Bishop C6
might as well try it maybe F4
F4 G5
ah E6 is hanging
let's still go for this
trying to create some complications
before
okay
this move's coming but then Queen here
now I can move
that's not pleasant
it's very unpleasant
this move just yeah crushes me okay
Knights defends a bishop attacks the
queen Defender Rook of that alignment
everything went wrong
yeah someone con ambulance for me
okay berserk
I'm trusting the extension
okay
some Kali or London maybe or whatever
this is
slightly unusual structure
probably get rid of the Knight
take play rookie eight
down on time but
positions very very good
okay
a pretty clean game
back in the top ten one point ahead of
Rebecca Harris
we're probably bound to play at some
points
playing this player again
yeah we drew earlier it was a crazy
um
like minor piece ending
so it's kind of like a reverse Cambridge
Springs but I have a good Bishop
oh take
so B5 I can take
probably threatening to take here to hit
the bishop
E4 looks interesting E4 Bishop G6 though
if I take
that's awkward for a block to recapture
as takes allows takes Knight's pinned B5
on the song
so I could throw in G4
E4 B5
spending too much time takes
let's try it
okay so B5 queen of oh wow
I didn't see that coming
four
[Music]
so E5 out of this move
Rook H4 I have this move
there's also nice now
try this
scary because it takes
but then maybe I just take back
take on A6
the rook's just trapped
Queen E7 King F1
funny Square for The Rook
I am temporarily down the piece though
between each six is an idea
a crazy position
[Music]
a queen H4 coming
H4 book H2
oh Queen H4 loses a rook
okay keep the attack
I'm hitting the pawn too
94 attacking defending
also this is hanging
I just Castle
a funny move
unexpected defending the rook and the
pawn
oh no my queen
uh oh
no my king
uh
I didn't see what to do I'm just getting
muted ah
Oh I thought it was so clever too
Crossing was such a bad move
oh I'm so sad I've only had three
seconds
is there any hope
that unbox this meeting
ah what a crazy crazy game
I felt like I was in very good control
towards end to
yeah just a little bit over creative
with uh castling
okay I can't let that tilt just
tell me too much
oh playing Tamil Jerry again
be berserk okay berserk time
ah this one take some Queen D2
it was a very sharp line
foreign
this now
no rush to take the Knight
oh no
letting another one slip
uh had a good position
[Music]
I'm not getting I'm probably getting
mated
oh it's a funny mate
yeah
what to do
I missed C2 is hanging
so Knight D5
uh was there a simple approach
I guess taking with other Knights
it's still a bit tricky though maybe I
should play King C1 first
thank you pesky Forks
okay still doing well overall in not the
end of the world still two hours to go
okay
stop for gamma time
this is one way to hopefully overcome
tilt
and hopefully not tilt more
so this is
probably the most common moves
Bishop E3 is playable
yeah so castling and Rook F1 are
most played Bishop B3 loses a pawn
objectively this line is fine for whites
but
I think Bishop E3 is a mistake because
of this
and then this
yeah the sign can be very effective for
Blitz
foreign
G5
Rook is pinned to the H2 Square
well it wants to play E5
so let's start with F6
trying to prevent this and prepare this
oh thank you Diego Aquila anti-tilt bits
thank you molfer
happy 15.
yeah
that's the point
I mean this should be good
start with Rook H4
going after B2
I didn't want to allow Queen D2 Rook f8
well up a minute
material Wise It's
um It's Tricky
I take this
and take
I just want to play Rook Hade and mate
Rook f8 is coming
I do have time
thank you
that's a risky line
21's idea
winning and winning on time is also an
idea
okay
check
fending
attacking
capturing
okay I'm taking a small break
um I have an appliance that won't stop
beeping it's a low battery I have to
take care of
so I'll be right back
I appreciate the hype and all the subs
um thank you
oh and all the bits too thing duster big
head Joel Rapha rafaskarov
I'll be back in just a moment
foreign
okay playing vladimirovic
who is this on Drake and or I think this
is on Dragon
play C3
take
this is the trickiest way to play in
this move order
I feel like I've looked at this at some
point
Bishop G5
this is G5 I haven't
wait a minute
I take
a defend
the queen side down to E7
the ideas of like taking or queen F3
C6 looks playable too
because if takes takes takes I take on
E7 in the end
to develop with tempo
wow
I think this is okay actually
because I have um Bishop E5 hitting the
Knight and
wait
I just miscalculated
oops
okay so I lost back the pawn
we traded Rooks
Rook D7 idea now the game keeps going
uh that's a good move
[Music]
um
I think I have to take
so I'm calculating a rookie here here
here hitting both Pawns
that's a move
okay
both pawns are hit
Bishop G7 probably be played
or not
very tricky
foreign
oh I don't have that move
to play this
I'm probably worse
trying to salvage a draw now threatening
perpetual
uh
everything's falling
thank you
oh to do
I want analyze a little bit
is there anything missed
engine says I miss Knight H4
I was scared the King was gonna run and
this would happen but
I have Rook B7
has a good position what to do
still doing well overall
33 points
and leader has 67
the fifth place isn't too far away
as a cool opening
I don't get that uh that line too often
uh to play here let's play something
traditional
hmm
may have lost a pawn but I don't think
it's takeable
even still I have C6
foreign
not the most pleasant but
let's see
C5 doesn't work
that's probably Bad c5s come in
by this move
C5 is still probably
a huge headache
I've had moved to
good move
yeah I'm just losing
any tricks
like there's not much I can do here
take
doesn't work
yeah well played
uh got into trouble it's probably
already bad after A6 maybe I have to
play A6 myself
okay what to do
Life Goes On
London
I had Bishop G4 earlier
okay this is more traditional not
yeah 97 looks natural
[Music]
um it's playable
foreign
black has a little bit of pressure here
ers
the Knight here is useful it helps
defend maybe get an outpost maybe attack
so this prevents Rook B3
mini lines
Rook B2 is coming
it doesn't work
now let's try this
open file
Queens you oh no Queen scene one F three
repeat two
nah
that's not good
oh nice move
uh tough position
[Music]
and time situation
trying to create a fortress but
it's not gonna help
oops
There Goes My Thing
I'm so happy
and that's why I wasn't resigning
I was not expecting that to happen
though
I mean black and just Queen there's no
need to take the knights but wow
oh wow
oh it's a miracle
yeah that's one reason to not resign
yeah I mean a lot of players when you're
black in that situation it's just it's
easy to get impatient
and that's basically what happened
okay
always need at least one of those for a
tournament like this
casting Queen side wow
okay let's go full
crazy mode
sack the night
opponent's not taking it
Knight C6 is coming
not terrible though oh it's terrible
oh it's really bad too
um
yeah
what to do
we have seen miracles happen in the past
in the very recent past
foreign
[Music]
back to tournament
all right it's been a while since I've
been on a streak
we're approaching the halfway point
I think for much of that game I was
trying to still process the previous
game
all right oh playing maradly strong
player
okay being solid
hey it's Lucky's guy
thanks for the five gifted
I appreciate that
position is not super Pleasant
foreign
C5 Rook A5
he wanted to set up this but
some funny alignment
a night was overworked
ah there's this no
wait what's happening
I just lost a piece
all the things are
never mind
though
well played
uh what to do good game
okay let's try and uh rebuild Knight C3
line
Joe Bava London
foreign
yeah so there's a line like Knight C6
Bishop B5 Bishop D7 takes
Bishop takes here here and then E6
I think this is a game between Leslie so
and Tata by
E I think I have to allow the queen Tree
in it
like I'm down the pond but there's
positional compensation
there's a structure like we might see E5
casting's coming
okay I do want to take
this does not look good for me
can I suck
ing might be might be my best hope
even though it looks
very questionable
for H5
really
I don't want to take that
foreign
[Music]
yeah my king is forever stuck
or my uh my Rook is forever stuck
I can block a win
what
yeah okay good fight
uh
I survived longer than I should have
probably
top 50.
yeah it's been a rough patch
but
I'll try and uh
try and break the losing streak out
um
I feel like my win rate with berserking
has been above average
this forces me to play quicker
I was a mouse left I meant to play
Bishop G4
so I'm giving time and material odds
uh maybe there's some compensation
just maybe
have to treat this as a Gambit
if I somehow don't lose this so it's
going to be a absolute miracle
does opponent want to draw
really
no let's play for a win
[Music]
I'm playing for a win despite the
uh the material gift
probably not the best decision
oh
I went to play Queen C4
Queen C4 would have given me counter
play too ah I don't know why I'm
mouseletting so much
in the one game
how bad how bad is it after Queen C4
yeah Queen C4 blocks battery oh that's
so sad
oh no my queen you bludgeaben happy 22.
all right
cling King's Crusher
the Snappers working back
one of the OG streamers
I got my lines confused
this looks okay
actually
maybe some G4 G5 idea
and blocks under pressure here
still playable
take take wait a minute tactics
and
E4
oh but e494
upon now
foreign
's ready to bolt
that's very hard to stop
yeah Knight D6 was Unstoppable
okay
I broke the losing streak I won a game
got the berserking points
still a lot of Chester to go
okay I played this player many times
uh please assuming
or whatever this is
D6 Bishop D7
foreign
didn't really accomplish much with Queen
B6
um I think I want to go for like A6 and
B5
new Rook p8
let's start with 95
I think this is only move
foreign
looks a little bit passive but
Bishop's going to be Unleashed takes I
take with knights
I'm probably threatening to take and
then put the nylon D6
A6 is weakening
go for this
there's a line like takes
takes takes and Bishop B2
it doesn't quite work though
so I'm down a pond but there's
compensation C file diagonal
Bishop H6
oh I missed Queen F4
I wonder if I can repeat and then get in
Queen F4
oh Queen F4 doesn't even win anything
because the thing's defended
oops
do I have wait do I have this now
tick
and taken Knight C4
triple Fork
just a lot of blind spots
like with Bishop
probably want to go for A5 very soon
B5
yeah now the file is guaranteed to open
[Music]
which means whites in
in a lot of danger
okay it is coming
okay kind of a weird game
I got the job done
all right oops
um I did not have a chance to even try
and berserk back there
okay this one
yeah Knight C3 is slightly dubious
because of this line
so this is one idea
ooh
oops
okay it's not that bad actually
I should have been aware of D6 though
thinking D1 is necessary
oh
so I'm threading this and this
and now King moves to the G file I've
rooked Yates
or Bishop E3
almost amazing that
that's a good move though
so I blocked attack
guaranteed discoveries
actually I'm threading made in one
where is my mate
Chuck
it feels close
foreign
I should just move quickly but it's an
interesting position
and take a pawn
Jack
why is it so frustrating
there we go
foreign
no
my beloved Pawn
oh I was so slow
uh I was trying to calculate the mates
and I don't think there was meat
um
yeah I should have just moved quicker
my biggest Advantage was minus five
oh yeah when I was up at peace
oh what to do
a lot of missed chances are
I didn't lose top 50 still
I'm trying um
clamango
have a good score against this player
E4 is maybe slightly questionable
I'm just trying to get activity
threading this
there there
play Queen A3 actually Queen B4
keeping the threats
I feel like a beginner like moving my
queen so many times in the opening
I shouldn't develop
now moving my Bishop multiple times
uh this move
no
up a pawn I'm down a lot of time
am I losing no I'm not
probably where so
I'm down upon
some boundaries
foreign
wait for it wait for it
no
I'm so sad
uh I always set up beautifully too
it was really subtle beautifully
okay we got uh
we got it once this tournament
berserk okay
London time
number 50 okay let's try and stay in the
top 50.
have to keep some composure
the queen E7 and 95 preventing Pawn E5
Bishop D7
a slightly strange move
oh thank you Gary
gifting to Jack and z
okay let's play a four so we have a
Stonewall setup
yeah G4 is ready to come
okay H3 as well
a very difficult position for lock the
G6 diffuses a bishop but weakens F6
so G6 runs into this move
I'm threatening to take and take
I guess H6 is the best try
and now G4
yeah using all my attacking resources
that's pretty much the dream attack
got the Rook oops
what that was got the Rook got the
bishop
upon coming to G5
review for victory
okay Knight G4
[Music]
I think this might be even cleaner
like Knight G4 would material but
this seems to be meeting
like Rook h8 is not working because the
books are not connected
it's a free Queen
black is fighting though
oops
that wasn't necessary
not the cleanest conversion
but still a conversion
okay
so that's one in a row
let's try and make it two
Alpha Peppers thank you Echo Tazo
the two prime Subs
I'm not sponsored by any um any chess
platform
I'm a free agent
so I play more on leechas but
I still play a decent amount of just.com
as well
I usually like to play in these um
like larger tournaments
like Tyler Arena title Tuesdays
what to do
trade
that was not a good move
oh no
I just got needed
unexpected checkmate
it should have been expected though my
king was on such a bad Square
okay same points as gotakovsky
uh let's play E4 mix it up a little bit
berserk back
timeout of time
okay I'll play A3
I don't usually play these structures
it's like a cheveningen Sicilian
hitting the pawn
uh
[Music]
I mean a big idea is to get a knight to
oh
I forgot about blocks ideas
maybe still okay though
for
the queen C4 Rook C1
threading this and this
wow
what is this imbalance
crazy position
[Music]
a little time for both of us
foreign
such a crazy position it's hard to
digest
uh taking the night was probably bad
I probably had to go for
yeah Queen A7 and
and push
good game though
playing David B who is this
abrotsky
yeah
used to be a young kid
staff for Gambit time
had this position earlier Bishop E3 was
a mistake
yeah that used to play Knight G4
this is what I like about the Saturn is
the opponent drains so much time early
on
and
even still it's hard to avoid the traps
have to be careful though
foreign
this
cutting this now
I still want to play this
okay I should be winning on time
foreign
that might be the first Grand Master
I've defeated with a Saturn this
tournament
be cool to do a compilation of like
beating Grand masters with the staffer
gamuts that doesn't happen too often
uh how's this move
play this
not gonna even try and win back the pawn
okay maybe I'll try a little bit
thank you
[Music]
I want to play this I didn't want to
allow c6o
that's a good move
maybe you can still try this
looks iffy though
what's the best way to avoid the
Stafford
and the best approach is to like go into
the staffer and just refute it
subjectively like almost losing her lack
if you want to avoid it you can play
anything other than E4 on move one
okay there's some compensation here
and 94
it's like a reverse Catalan got my
Bishop
an id4 might be coming
[Music]
so E5
something to consider
it blocks a bishop though so I don't
want to commit too soon
maybe H5 first
I missed a fork
I saw it right after I moved to
okay now I have this but not winning
material
but I did get rid of the lights for a
bishop and I keep my own light story
Bishop
so there's compensation
five Queen B6
now the rook's tied down and attacked
I don't think I want to take it though
go for
some mating ideas
allowing up for
wait take take take take take
go for this
menacing formation
[Music]
the idea is now to play H4 use the H
file and
eventually break through Maybe
this move
Knight C6 I can take
I'm down how many pawns down three Pawns
[Music]
There Goes My Rook
Down The Rook in two Pawns
of the king is guaranteed to be
discovered checked
at least a draw I play for a win
I might as well
okay wow
I'm not sure how I won that and somehow
it worked out
oh man
trying to get back to over 2600.
here we go
double berserk
this opening again
I had this earlier
play a different style of her like
compared to earlier
yeah
opponent wasn't expecting G5 there
foreign
okay 35th
I don't know why it's telling me it's a
berserk a GM who's
almost my same rating
uh okay
Patrol opening
we're probably gonna see a hippo
try and play aggressively here
already losing a pawn
not the highest quality chess
some pressure though
wow
okay check another seven this feels like
a beginner game
I got hung upon blacks played a terrible
opening
it still takes work
so Knight E5 is now possible
just want to play B4
I could have taken here
maybe F4 coming
oops
that's not good
still pressure though
it might be winning the exchange again
foreign
yeah I had the chance to take C7 as well
okay top 40.
oh this is a person who stalemated me
earlier
uh what was the opening now
a slightly different opening this time
foreign
or not
I'm inclined to take
try and play very positionally
that was a blunder
maybe it's not so bad though
as I do hit A6
and I can take with the Rook
that was a big trade
that's probably worse now
yeah losing a pawn
losing multiple Pawns
no my Pawns
all right I'm trying to fight
yeah my night is completely stuck
only down three Pawns
could be worse
it could be down four Pawns
oh it's getting worse
going after G7
wow
it does defend
a pun's going to be ultra careful like
the stale Matrix to
because of what happened to our previous
game
you still never know
oh no my Rook
okay well played
uh good game
yeah against other players I'd probably
resign but uh
I was hoping for a double miracle
yeah at some point the queen side
crumbled that game
oh I played this person in uh title
Tuesday recently
I think
also a streamer shout out to my opponent
I might as well take
foreign
so that user of ticks I have Vision A3
Queen D1 Queen dig C3
I can't resist looks like too much fun
the king doesn't have a super attractive
Square
speaking of super attractive
look at that Bishop
okay so now the fifth ranks open
foreign
never resign when you have the bishop
hair
oh there goes half my Bishop pair
there goes my king
I forgot how the Knight moved for a
moment
okay
41st Place
what to do
have a good position had a really nice
Bishop
so 54 points
just under 31 minutes left
um
try and get on a street cover let's hold
off on berserking
okay this is one of the more critical
lines
oh what's the theory here
there's some line where we sacked the
night
I'm forgetting the theory
foreign
s generally just lead to really complex
positions
like I'm down two ponds but a lot of
pressure
might be three ideas
pinned Queens is a bit of a Target
if Bishop D7 I think I can take it takes
its mate
Bishop G7
Knight B3
you're getting some time advantage
yes now look I think the thread is
Knight D4
a D4 Queen C5
some A3 move also no I can't take
very very confusing line
now if I take
so looks like I'm winning material but
maybe not
probably not
unless I have F3
takes
let's try this
oh good move
okay I'm down two pawns what to do
the thing on the edge
literally
foreign
wow
I won on time
I'm not sure how that happened but
I guess I'll take it
oh
I should have been losing at so many
points that game
I really have to learn that line
it's like one of the more critical
London lines
all right not playing the London
uh I would have berserk back but
okay
we have one of these
um
let's take
a Grand Prix attack
hitting two Pawns
uh
you have to take
oh this is looking good
starting this
I think the idea is to lift the other
Rook to H3
at King G8 I think I can take
because I removed the queen and then
when the thing
okay
that was nice
top 40.
two in a row so this next game will if I
win I LeapFrog a lot of people
probably don't want a berserk
well maybe I should have
have some Italian
foreign
[Music]
I have to save the bishop
centers just exploding
there's a pin down attacked
that's a move
and my Bishop's actually kind of out of
play
take and
this
this first
and my Bishop is so bad
what's that Drake song
I like bad Bishops that's my problem
uh let's play this
maybe I can win A4
maybe not but maybe
Maybe
there we go
oh my Bishop
okay
dirty flagging coming
it's hard for white to untangle
I'm triangulating
or trapezoidalating oops I I repeat it
uh uh I was trying to move in a
trapezoid
to do
okay I think it draws a fair result
There Goes My streak though
all right not too much time left
um Queen F3 is interesting
D5
what does this line E4 take take
inventing some new new opening here
fresh invention
it's like a Halloween London
but I sacked a rook
okay one I won the Knight so I'm down
the exchange
play this move
[Music]
foreign
moving way too slowly
I mean the knights should be eventually
trapped
develop
that's not good
maybe it's not bad though
foreign
that's really not good
I'm down two exchanges
might win one back I might not
hey it's a triple Fork let's go oh my
king
uh
I'll saw it coming
okay
uh it's towards the end of the
tournament
my only way to get to top 30 is to
berserk
and win quickly with funny opening traps
foreign
can't defend the bishop the the clutch
Knight on a is controlling B6
okay
all right 38th
chesfus who's this Spain
have a similar line against komsky
earlier
a knight's a good defensive piece here
got my battery
got my horsey
let's take first
what to do
got my targets
got a pin
I mean this looks crushing
everything's attacked dull I'm pinned
though
right
take
foreign
's been hanging for a while
uh
what a crazy position though
yeah my Bishop was pinned
maybe it wasn't so crushing
I burned a lot of time there too
okay still top 40.
top 30 is going to be difficult
okay
berserk every game now
I'm yoloing
I don't think the Knight is capturable
I'll just leave the night there
yeah if a pawn gets to G6 and it's
it leads to so many mating ideas
hitting this and this
interesting position
that's a pin that's a pin
oh that's a good move
unbox finding good moves
take
okay somehow it's still okay
thank you
okay let's go
gabriellin
not a great position
over D5
ideas to take and then Bishop C4
taken with a pawn
clever move
thank you black ninja or bread Ninja
or breadstick ninja appreciate the
gifted Subs
foreign
I'll take that
okay
all right time for one more game if I
berserk win the next game I probably
leap into the top 30.
a nice score
those games should count for the
tournament
um
wandering upon
maybe winning back upon
or just happened
no my bad Bishop again
[Music]
okay this should be uh
should be winning
let's go
pairings are closed
or am I
top 30
where am I
30th
oh dear
this matters for the prediction
20 20 something seconds left
will I stay in the top 30.
so much suspense
who's behind me a lot of people behind
me
like if any of these people like win
oh it's been gonna be close
three seconds
hey it's over
30th Place let's go
okay
well that concludes the tournament
had a decent finish
with three wins
74 points
good job to this person
contra
oh this is jaspin Jose Martinez
and then nerdinsky and
what's second Chicago
in third
I didn't play nerdisky today
I hope people enjoyed watching
thanks everyone for being here